[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin willkommen an einem der
heißesten tage des jahres kristin otto
hat später wieder mehr über den
bundesliga steinau der countdown läuft
guten abend und hier sind einige unserer
heutigen themen
hitzewelle auf dem höhepunkt extreme
temperaturen und trockenheit belasten
mensch und natur im berliner grunewald
brennt ist warum ist noch unklar
bayerns furcht vor energieknappheit die
union chefs drängen die berliner ampel
zu längeren akw-laufzeiten
und chinas demonstration militärischer
stärke die armee beginnt ein
großangelegtes manöver und umzingelt
taiwan
aktuell in deutschland immer noch
temperaturen um die 37 grad zur
inzwischen dritten hitzewelle des jahres
gleich mehr bei uns hohe werte und
trockenheit begünstigen aktuell ein
großfeuer am rande der hauptstadt
ausgebrochen ist es am frühen morgen im
südwesten berlins mitten im grunewald
außerdem hat es gewaltige explosionen
gegeben auf einem sprengplatz der
polizei die abus autobahn ist gesperrt
auch die angrenzende bahnstrecke erst
konnte die feuerwehr nur eindämmen weil
unter anderem munition und
feuerwerkskörper auf dem sprengplatz
lagern insgesamt rund 25 tonnen eine
hochgefährliche situation über die hans
jürgen pohl berichtet immer wieder
explosionen feuer im berliner grunewald
ausgerechnet auf dem sprengplatz der
polizei war es in der letzten nacht
ausgebrochen hier lagern
weltkriegsmunition und feuerwerkskörper
für kontrollierte sprengungen
schwieriger einsatz für die feuerwehr
die lage ist enorm außergewöhnlich einen
sprengplatz mit munition kampfmitteln
und feuerwerkskörpern hat erhebliche
gefahren unsere ersten einsatzkräfte die
heute morgen um 33 tätig geworden sind
mussten sich zurückziehen den sind
trümmerteile um die köpfe frei waren in
höchster lebensgefahr
die rauchwolken waren vielerorts im
berliner westen zu sehen die brandstelle
liegt mitten im größten waldgebiet der
hauptstadt weit entfernt und von
wohnhäusern mitten in der nacht kam der
erste alarm schon am morgen waren
wasserwerfer und hubschrauber vor ort
durch bis zur stunde konnten die
feuerwehrleute immer noch nicht zum
brandherd vordringen beschränkten sich
darauf das feuer am rand einzudämmen
berlins regierende bürgermeisterin
machte sich am nachmittag selbst ein
bild der löscharbeiten abwägungen ob ein
naherholungsgebiet wirklich der
geeignete ort für einen sprengplatz ist
es wäre viel schwieriger wenn hier im
näheren umfeld wohnbebauung wäre wir
müssen uns eher darüber gedanken machen
wie wir in zukunft mit diesem
sprengplatz umgehen und ob auf berliner
stadtgebiet ein solcher ort der richtige
ist der verkehr auf der angrenzenden
autobahn abos ist bis auf weiteres
unterbrochen gesperrt auch der schienen
weg nach potsdam anwohner sind bisher
nicht gefährdet und
vor ort für uns ist stephan hain
stefanie weiß man inzwischen warum das
feuer ausgebrochen ist und wie gehen die
löscharbeiten voran
warum das feuer ausgebrochen ist es nach
wie vor völlig unklar
die feuerwehr wurde ja zunächst zu einem
waldbrand alarmiert und als sie dann
hier ankamen und schon bis auf dem
springplatz waren sahen sie ein gebäude
das in vollbrand stand und dann gab es
die ersten explosionen die die feuerwehr
gehört hat in die wand so heftig dass
sie sich erst einmal zurückgezogen haben
die polizei die zuständig ist für die
vermittlung die waren überhaupt noch
nicht auf dem gelände und es ist auch
ziemlich unter wie viel die da noch vor
finden weil seit 18 uhr gibt es hier
immer wieder detonationen wir sind 1,2
km weg und hören es hier richtig kräftig
schrumpfen das hat auch dazu geführt
dass der erkundungs roboter jetzt erst
mal aus diesem sprengplatz gebiet
zurückgezogen ist und die feuerwehr im
moment nur wieder an den rändern recht
und es noch eine weile dauern wird bis
sie sich überhaupt wieder bis ins innere
vortasten danke für die information live
aus berlin stephanie heim
die trockenheit und die hohen
temperaturen die sorgen nicht nur in
berlin für probleme ganz deutschland
ächzt ja heute unter der hitze besonders
betroffen der nordosten und südwesten
des landes dort kletterte das
thermometer über 35 grad in bad
kreuznach in rheinland-pfalz da wurden
sogar 39 grad gemessen es ist eine
extreme belastung vor allem für ältere
menschen und die natur berichtet antoine
kurschilgen
es sieht ein wenig aus wie die wüste in
texas ist aber sömmerda in thüringen
laut deutschem wetterdienst der
trockenste ort deutschlands eine
steppenlandschaft grüne flecken sucht
man hier vergeblich ähnliche bilder aus
brandenburg auch hier herrscht an
einigen orten dürre ganze seen und
flüsse drohen komplett auszutrocknen die
natur leidet unter der hitze auch viele
menschen müssen gucken wie sie damit
zurecht kommen die bewohner dieses
pflegeheims in köln haben offenbar einen
guten weg gefunden sie müssen besonders
vor der hitze geschützt werden
morgens wenn ich aufstehe der merklichen
leichter schwindel
übel sein
unter trinke meinen kaffee energischem
ist kein appetit
im hessischen heppenheim kletterte das
thermometer heute auf mehr als 30 grad
da kam eine abkühlung im freibad gerade
recht
also schon ganz schön heftig also da
kann man froh sein ein freibad so nah
dran zu haben also ich mache sonst viel
sport da halte ich mich zurzeit jetzt
auch mal ein bisschen zurück der
tagelang
spielplätze sind leergefegt aber
schwimmbad ist dann doch eine gute
alternative die schöne seite der hitze
im norden ein strandtag in schleswig
holstein den nutzten viele um sich
abzukühlen denn auch hier war es heute
sehr heiß
aufgeheizt auch die debatte zur
deutschen energiekrise seit wochen wird
über eine mögliche laufzeitverlängerung
für atomkraftwerke diskutiert die ampel
regierung ist uneins die union fordert
sie seit wochen in bayern wo die
regierung in sachen energiewende einiges
liegen ließ trafen sich heute csu
ministerpräsident und cdu-chef märz sie
fordern noch in diesem monat eine
entscheidung alexander pohl das
atomkraftwerk isar 2 bei landshut ist
noch einmal ein objekt der begierde
der besuch heute vor allem für die
kameras weder friedrich merz noch markus
söder haben in sachen laufzeit etwas zu
entscheiden daher ein weiterer appell
der weiterbetrieb eines solchen
kernkraftwerks ist technisch möglich er
ist personell möglich und er ist
rechtlich möglich noch läuft ein zweiter
stresstest im auftrag des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums
ob ein weiterbetrieb der atomkraftwerke
zur sicherung des strombedarfs notwendig
ist besonders bayern fürchtet
energieknappheit wenn atomstrom ab 2023
nicht mehr fließt bislang galt öl und
gas aus russland als günstiger ersatz
während bayern davon in den vergangenen
jahren immer mehr importiert hat sind zb
die einfuhren in das
bevölkerungsreichste land nordrhein
westfalen um fast die hälfte gefallen
ein grund für die bayerische
abhängigkeit anders als in nrw gibt es
hier keine großen kohlevorkommen nach
dem atomausstieg setzte man aufs gas
mögliche wege aus dieser abhängigkeit
blockierte bayern oft selbst
stromtrassen etwa die windenergie aus
dem norden in den süden transportieren
gegen sie gab es massiven widerstand
ebenso gegen windräder auch die csu
sorgte sich um das landschaftsbild und
ihre popularität in meiner wahrnehmung
hat sich auch die staatsregierung
letztendlich ja hat nicht diejenigen
unterstützt die die energiewende
wirklich wollen sondern sie hat
diejenigen unterstützt die sie
eigentlich verhindern wollen und das ist
uns als wirtschaftszweig natürlich
schwer vor die füße gefallen dass bayern
etwa die photovoltaik massiv ausgebaut
hat erkennen experten durchaus an doch
damit sagen sie komme man eben nicht
durch den kalten winter
wer eine erkältung hat kann sich seit
heute wieder telefonisch krankschreiben
lassen und zwar bis zu sieben tage lang
auch eine verlängerung um bis zu einer
woche ist per telefon möglich
hintergrund sind die und corona zahlen
die regel gilt vorerst bis ende november
panzer rollen kampfjets steigen auf
raketen fliegen china setzt um was es
ankündigte in einem groß angelegten
militär manöver mit scharfer munition
wird die blockade taiwans simuliert all
das kurz nachdem taiwan besuch von us
spitzenpolitikerin pelosi durch den sich
china stark provoziert fühlt ulf röller
es sind diese bilder die chinas führung
in die welt senden will
raketenabschuss in richtung taiwan
peking plant eine see und luftweg a.de
um seinen besitzanspruch deutlich zu
machen für peking gehört taiwan zu
festlandchina die insel ist vom
chinesischen militär umzingelt mit
scharfer munition finden die manöver
stadt das chinesische fernsehen feiert
grafisch die einschläge und erklärt den
einsatz
das manöver betrifft eine ganze reihe
von wichtigen militärischen regionen so
wollen wir die
unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen der
taiwanesischen separatisten unterbinden
china lässt die muskeln spielt eine
warnung an amerika das sich als
schutzmacht taiwans empfindet der besuch
von pelosi wirkt in taiwan nach 23
millionen menschen leben hier viele
haben angst vor krieg
taiwans verteidigungswall ist schwach
wenn jetzt ein krieg ausbricht wissen
wir nicht was wir tun sollen
taiwans regierung versucht diese angst
ihrer bevölkerung zu nehmen sie hat ihr
militär in alarmbereitschaft versetzt
wir werden unsere selbstverteidigung
hochfahren erklärt taiwans sprecherin
des aussenministeriums uns eng mit
unseren verbündeten wie amerika
absprechen china lässt seine kampfjets
nur wenige kilometer an taiwans küste
vorbei fliegen presidential bezeichnet
seine drohgebärden als militärmanöver
peking will angst machen aber wohl
keinen krieg führen
drei tage dauert chinas manöver drei
tage ausnahmezustand in einer
gefährlichen region
ein russisches gericht hat die us
basketballspielerin britney kreiner
wegen drogenschmuggels zu neun jahren
haft verurteilt in reiners gepäck war
eine kleine menge cannabis öl entdeckt
worden die usa werfen moskau vor der
prozess sei politisch motiviert und
bieten russland einen
gefangenenaustausch an um 31 freilassung
zu erwirken
jetzt in den libanon zwei jahre ist es
her dass dort eine katastrophale
explosion teile perus in schutt und
asche legte tausende tonnen falsch
gelagertes ammoniumnitrat machten den
hafen der stadt dem erdboden gleich mehr
als 200 menschen starben über 6000
wurden verletzt und das in einem land
das ohnehin krisen gebeutelt ist
politisch gelähmt wirtschaftlich am
boden und wegen russlands krieg gegen
die ukraine wird jetzt auch noch der
weizen knapp nina niebergall
hier backen sie noch was den menschen im
libanon so dringend fehlt weizen ist
knapp brot selten und teuer geworden
ich habe mich heute nacht um 1 schon
angestellt und bis morgens um sieben
gewartet dann bilden sich hier ewig
lange schlangen
ich habe es geschafft eine packung
fladenbrot zu bekommen aber wir sind
vier personen das reicht nicht um
überhaupt weiter fladenbrot anbieten zu
können brauchen sie dringend weizen aus
der ukraine
bald soll der erste getreidefrachter von
dort ankommen für den bäckerei besitzer
allerdings nicht gerade ein grund zur
freude
ich weiß nicht viel über das schiff das
aus der ukraine kommen soll nur dass es
mit mais beladen ist meist bringt uns
bäckern gar nichts
der libanon bezieht mehr als 70 prozent
seines weizens aus der ukraine und die
menschen leiden sowieso schon unter
armut hyperinflation
korrupten politikern
ausgerechnet zum jahrestag der
verheerenden explosion stürzten die
getreidesilos am hafen von beirut weiter
wirkt wie ein symbol für ein stark
beschädigtes land
menschenrechtsorganisationen fordern
endlich aufklärung die politiker die das
zu verantworten haben haben überhaupt
kein bedürfnis dass das aufgeklärt wird
denn sie stecken mitten in einem
korruptionssumpf was natürlich
schrecklich ist für die überlebenden und
für die angehörigen der leute die
gestorben sind es brauche eine
internationale untersuchung unter
leitung der un damit die menschen im
libanon abschließen können zumindest mit
einer der vielen krisen im land
der klimawandel lässt weltweit gletscher
schmelzen jüngstes beispiel der größte
deutsche gletscher unter der zugspitze
der schneeferner ist vier wochen früher
als sonst komplett schneefrei es gibt
aber auch weniger ausnahmen der perito
moreno gletscher in argentinien genauer
in patagonien er gehört zu den letzten
gletschern auf der welt die trotz des
klimawandels noch nicht an masse
verlieren christoph röck rat war dort
der perito moreno gletscher in
argentinien im süden patagoniens ist der
superstar unter den gletschern
südamerikas
[Musik]
er gehört zu den letzten auf der welt
die insgesamt nicht schrumpfen und zu
dem klimawandel zu trotzen scheinen wir
begleiten drei forscher auf ihrem weg
ins noch ewige eis warum der perito
moreno stabil bleibt ist nicht
abschließend geklärt die wissenschaftler
hoffen durch ihn andere gletscher besser
verstehen zu koennen sie treiben löcher
ins eis um anhand von meßstetten die
veränderungen abzulesen sicher ist der
perito moreno ist eine seltene ausnahme
weltweit ist die lage der gletscher
dramatisch
verkleinert werden ob die gletscher
ziehen sich zurück und zwar in den
letzten 20 25 jahren schneller als in
den letzten 2000 jahre
gletscher sind nicht nur ein wichtiger
wasserspeicher ihr eis kühlt auch die
atmosphäre wenn sie schmelzen schreitet
die erderwärmung noch schneller voran es
droht eine kettenreaktion deren folgen
niemand abschätzen kann doch lukas ruiz
glaubt daran dass es noch nicht zu spät
ist
wir müssen um jeden preis vermeiden dass
noch mehr kohlendioxid ausgestoßen wird
wir müssen unsere verbindung zur natur
im allgemeinen verbessern wir müssen
wieder in kontakt mit dem kommen was um
uns herum passiert
die emotionale botschaft eines
wissenschaftlers der noch immer an die
lernfähigkeit der menschheit glaubt auch
wenn die gletscher der welt uns nicht
mehr viel zeit lassen
nun gut die bilder bei dieser hitze mehr
davon die ganze dokumentation
geheimnisvolle anden heute abend 22 uhr
15 im zdf oder wann immer sie wollen in
der mediathek oder in unserer app
noch mal zurück zur hitze viele suchen
dieser tage abkühlung im wasser
besonders außerhalb von schwimmbädern
kann das aber auch richtig gefährlich
werden so die deutsche lebens rettungs
gesellschaft dlrg seit jahresbeginn sind
demnach mindestens
199 menschen in deutschen gewässern
ertrunken 90 prozent von ihnen in
unbeaufsichtigten seen und flüssen
einige können es kaum noch abwarten
morgen abend ist es soweit die fußball
bundesliga handeln und zwar richtig
ansehnlichen partie äußerst reizvoll in
frankfurt empfängt die eintracht als
europa-league-gewinner den rekordmeister
fc bayern münchen
und beide vereine präsentierten sich
bereits vor saisonstart in ansprechender
form verbuchten jeweils verheißungsvolle
erfolge feiern mit überragendem muss ja
gerade erst supercup-sieger auch
neuzugang maniche traf beim 5 2 3 in
leipzig doch auch frankfurts trainer
glasner hochzufrieden mit einem klasse
spiel seiner durch mario götze
verstärkten eintracht der ball lief rund
beim 14 0 pokalsieg in magdeburg zwei
tore kanada und insgesamt drei treffer
eingeleitet von wm siegtorschütze mario
götze er ist ja sehr intelligent und ein
herausragender fußballer ich freue mich
dass ich morgen sie
wünsche mir auch dass er gut spielt aber
als nicht
überragend sein kollege will gegen die
super-bayern mutig bleiben wir wollen
den bayern richtigen fight liefern wir
wollen ihnen wenig räume geben und die
die sie unser anbieten bestmöglich
ausnutzen und seinen spielern danach
wieder gratulieren zu können
und frankfurts trainer ist samstagabend
im sportstudio spannend wird auch das
berliner derby union gegen hertha
zuletzt drei siege für das team von urs
fischer diese serie will die alte dame
unter dem neuen trainer sandro schwarz
stoppen union hertha härter union das
derby ist wetterunabhängig
eine heiße angelegenheit und mit ihm
erhofft sich hertha bsc endlich den
erfolg für den sie so viel investiert
haben andres schwarz hat die nötige
leidenschaft die alle mitreißen soll
doch dann der fehlstart in die saison in
der ersten runde des dfb pokals ist
härter gegen braunschweig ausgeschieden
zudem haben sie in der letzten saison in
hin und rückrunde gegen union verloren
darum gilt es jetzt klaren kopf zu
behalten und dennoch aber auch mit einer
hohen leidenschaft hohen maximalen
bereitschaft am samstag anzutreten union
ist mit einem zittersieg im pokal in die
saison gestartet doch gut aufgestellt
und als tabellenfünfter der letzten
saison können sie selbstbewusst ins
derby gehen
somit zeit dass der ball rollt
dankeschön christin und zum schluss noch
was für fans spektakulärer naturgewalten
und komplizierter zum brecher in island
ist wieder der vulkan fia gerade als
fidel ausgebrochen seit gestern sprudelt
lava aus einem etwa 300 meter langen
entriss das zieht auch touristen an
dieses spiel mit dem feuer der vier grad
als pferde ist wiederholungstäter mit
langem atem sein ausbruch im vergangenen
jahr dauerte gut sechs monate mal sehen
wie lange es diesmal dauern an senden
so nach der hitze kommt leichter
abkühlung mehr dazu gleich im wetter mit
biss den termin zum heute journal um
21.45 begrüßt sie christian sievers das
war es von uns wir wünschen einen
entspannten abend mit kaltgetränk und
freuen uns dann wenn sie morgen wieder
dabei sind
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die
außergewöhnliche hitze des heutigen
tages wird allmählich verdrängt von
dieser kaltfront die uns von nordwesten
her erreicht und in der nacht für
heftige schauer und gewitter sorgen wird
vor der kaltfront erreicht uns noch
warme luft und so steigen die
temperaturen vor allem im südosten noch
mal kräftig an in der kommenden nacht
also heftige gewitter von nordwesten und
westen her das sind gewitter im unwetter
bereich mit starkregen hagel und
sturmböen im südosten merkt man kaum
etwas davon bei tiefsten temperaturen
von 14 grad in schleswig holstein und
zum beispiel im osten bei 22 grad und
morgen am vormittag heftige gewitter von
westen her und auch im norden gewittert
ganz im süden scheint die sonne zum
nachmittag verlagert sich das ganze
richtung süden schon wieder unwetter mit
hagel sturm und platzregen von
nordwesten her wird es allmählich
ruhiger bei höchsten temperaturen bis 35
grad im südosten und 34 richtung neiße
20 grad an der nordsee die kommenden
tage schauer und gewitter im süden
deutschlands am samstag bis 27 grad und
danach steigen die temperaturen schon
wieder an ein schöner abend